هذه الطفله التي عمرها 15 يوم الان سوف
نحاول استضافه يا عمي تفضل يا عم سوف نعم
بالراحه بالراحه
كتب لها عمر جديد الحمد لله الحمد لله
المستشفى اللي ولدت فيها انضربت مستشفى
الساحه ما اعرف اذا انضربت ولا لا لكن
يعني احنا طلعنا قبل يومين بس من الاحداث
نحن في الخرطوم كافوري طردت لقصف كثير
والله جاتنا الطلقات جاتني في البيت وصلت
البيت يعني
ايوه على طول يعني ما اخذ صراحه اي وقت
يعني صراحه احسن معامله وب
سرعه الحمد لله اكثر لحظه انت قلتي فيها
على طفلتك والله لحظه
[موسيقى]
ملك فيصل وصلت للمياه الاقليميه السعوديه
ايش اول احساس بادر لذه الحمد لله
مواليد المملكه واحنا عايشين هنا واهلي
هنا لهم اكثر من 30 سنه فالحمد لله دائما
المملكه ايوه اشكال السودان احنا بس
التخصص ايوه يعني احنا اصلا مواليد كلهم
مولودين هنا الحمد لله فما شفنا المملكة
الا كل خير الحمد لله شكرا شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات